à québec on retrouve lagacé vice
présidente chez québec international
bonsoir madame magasins nordstrom
escalier vous on vous a invité à
plusieurs reprises au cours des
dernières années pour parler des
missions de recrutement des missions
d'affaires à l'étranger
comment votre organisation s'organise je
gère présentement ses activités
internationales avec cette pandémie de
lakovic 19 il y avait aussi les mesures
annoncées par le premier ministre
trudeau
c'est sûr que de notre côté c'est une
préoccupation vraiment quotidienne parce
que développer ses affaires internes et
à l'international ça se fait de deux
façons soit qu'on se déplace soit un
représentant québec est en national qui
se déplace à l'étranger pour faire
valoir les opportunités de notre région
soit qu'on se déplace avec une
délégation pour participer soit une
foire commerciale au grand salon
d'affaires ou soit qu'on se déplace
aussi avec des entreprises pour mener un
projet en soi c'est à dire comme une
mission de recrutement ou soit l'
inverse c'est à dire que on développe
nos affaires à l'international en
accueillant à québec
des représentants de compagnies ou des
représentants internationaux qui
viennent à québec pour voir et saisir
des opportunités
donc lorsque je comprends quand vous
décrivez ça c'est que tout est arrêté là
actuellement non tout n'est pas arrêtée
justement ça fait nous deux semaines au
moins que nous avons mis en place des
politiques vraiment permettant une
analyse très pointue de ce qu'on doit
faire dans ce type de situation donc la
préoccupation première est bien sûr la
sécurité des gens donc et d'éviter une
de favoriser la propagation du virus si
nous avons été en contact soit l'état
qu'on proviennent de l'international au
soin qu'on a été racontée avec quelqu'un
qui provient de l'international donc on
aura chaque situation l'analyse vraiment
le contexte et voir vraiment on est
capable de gérer la situation
mais je comprends mais quand même
premier ministre dit que toute personne
qui vient de l'étranger doit se placer
en quarantaine
oui on ne peut pas accueillir personne
on peut pas que y'a personne mais ce qui
est on doit faire preuve d'innovation et
de stratégie c'est à dire que dans une
situation que je vais vous donner un cas
concret par exemple nous avions une
mission de recrutement qui était prévue
à la fin mars début
avril au madagascar donc nous avons
immédiatement consulter les entreprises
fait part de l'état de situation à
l'époque on parle d'environ il ya deux
semaines environ
la situation n'était pas celle qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui mais nous avons
quand même analysé le taux de 10,2 en
bifurquant vers la france pour se rendre
au madagascar des gens commençaient que
certains vols étaient limités sur le
madagascar donc immédiatement nous avons
pris la décision non pas d'annuler la
mission mais plutôt de la faire
bifurquer va diffuser vers un modèle qui
est virtuel donc pour nos entreprises
déjà habitué à supporter des conférences
ont fait ça par visioconférence dans son
genre les candidats à l'international
sont déjà sélectionnés sont déjà donc
seront convoqués à une rencontre qui va
se faire tout simplement par
visioconférence ou par ces cas pas
pareil c'est pas pareil parce que
l'entreprise bien sûr lmp1 16 et là le
savoir est d'une personne créer cette
relation de proximité jugée l'ajustement
de de la personnalité de l'individu
sauf qu'on a développée avec des années
cette capacité là avec nos entreprises à
pourvoir quand même est en mesure de
juger de cette dimension là et d'être en
mesure de déployer certaines choses donc
l'objectif n'est pas de nécessairement
dans tous les cas d' annuler mais de
favoriser justement un contact pourrait
être différent qui peut être un contact
un premier contact permettra par la
suite d'aller un d'autres étapes
on essaie vraiment avec l'entreprise de
trouver des moyens qui lui permettra de
continuer ses affaires et surtout de 2
dans sa planification qu'elle a fait de
pouvoir avoir des gens qui comble ses
besoins de main d'oeuvre ou de
développer de nouveaux marchés bien
d'attendre et de pouvoir le second
sommes nous en train d'apprendre ici
donc sans poignée de main finalement on
peut faire des affaires quand même on
peut voir des enfants on peut faire des
affaires qui on peut du moins est en
mesure de bien mettre la table à une
relation qui pourra se développer
peut-être différemment ou un rythme
différent mais on va prendre sûrement à
l'intérieur de cette situation qu'il ya
des façons de faire qu'on peut maximiser
autrement et sur lequel mon
doit actuellement la mise et pour
justement éviter le plus possible qu'ils
aient une coupure complète des activités
des blacks ça vous inquiète quand même
toutes ces annulations de conférences et
congrès si rassemblement chez québec
international
ça crée des inquiétudes ça crée des
inquiétudes bien sûr sur chez nos
entreprises parce que le questionnement
est quand même profond est ce que par
exemple j'ai je m'apprêtais justement a
signé une entente je m'apprêtais à
accueillir un par exemple un fournisseur
qui provenaient de l'international
qu'est ce que je fais comment je fais
est-ce que ça met en péril justement
certaines certains et certaines
progressions au croissance au niveau de
mon entreprise
et ça ça les inquiète énormément donc on
doit être en mesure de les accompagner
là dedans et d'être en mesure de leur
proposer
quand même des moyens qui sont
alternatif pour être capable justement
d'avoir une certaine continuité au
niveau des affaires actuellement on
n'est pas encore en mesure de voir
l'impact financier parce que lorsqu'on
participe à certains événements
internationaux les retombées de ces
événements là sont quand même énorme
donc c'est ça qui va avoir une
diminution d'un pack par rapport aux
retombées ont pourtant vu mais jusqu'à
présent sincèrement la réponse au temps
des entreprises que de nous nogent à
l'étranger est excellent on a parlé tout
à l'heure du recrutement international
mais c'est la même chose au niveau
commercial
on avait par exemple dans le cas de la
semaine numérique à québec donc le web à
québec qui devait se tenir au début
d'avril
on était au chapeau tu es un peu toutes
les rencontres d'entreprise entreprises
le 'b to b' entre entreprises la semaine
sera probablement annulé la décision est
tombée à cette heure-ci l'homme et nous
ce qu'on a fait c'est que toutes les
normes b to b seront mis en place pour
les entreprises dans le cadre de cette
semaine est de façon virtuelle de façon
virtuelle ces mots clés en tout cas il
ne l'agacé merci beaucoup merci à vous
merci